so what is this new bug food gonna look
like well here it is
hey my name is uh Chef Joseph Yoon
edible insect Ambassador and we were to
raise awareness and appreciation for
sustainable forms of protein
how can we sustainably feed
the growing population around the world
and it doesn't suggest that we want to
get rid of any how do we add something
to our diets and maybe look towards the
past for solutions to the Future they're
incredibly nutritious they're
sustainable
but most importantly
they can be declared absolutely
deliciously
so as long as we're switching from
ribeye to cicadas we might as well make
it good Chef Joseph Yoon is trying his
best to do that he's the executive
director of Brooklyn bugs an
organization that without any shame at
all promotes bug food he joins us on set
now Chef Yun thank you so much for
coming on thank you so much for having
me so we're assuming leaving politics
aside we're just assuming for the
purpose of this segment this is just
inevitable we're going to be eating bugs
so we might as well make the best of it
and you have definitely made the best of
it tell us what kind of bugs you cook I
cook with a lot of different insects and
really crickets are like a really big
Gateway bug if you will but you know and
I will well one of the really big
reasons that we love to highlight this
is that it's so fun it's delicious we
can talk about sustainability and
everything but if it doesn't taste good
it's not going to be successful I agree
with you completely I don't know what's
in a Wheat Thin but I'll eat them so is
there any bug that you won't prepare as
food that's too far for you well there
are I only work with bugs that I know
are scientifically proven to be edible
for human consumption yes yeah so and
and you know a big part is like how can
we reimagine edible insects and it's not
something that we're trying to force on
anybody it's just like one option that
we have to consider as a right source so
I think just before we get into what you
prepared today I think everyone has the
same question in mind will cockroaches
be on the menu are they ever prepared
cockroaches you know all the insects
that are that that we use are farmed or
harvested specifically for human
consumption okay and cockroaches may be
on that list but I personally don't
really think that we're ready for
cockroaches just yet good you speak for
me when you say that I'm not right but
what do what is that I go right to the
all right so we yeah I wanted to bring
some sweet and savory okay and so here
we have uh cricket caramel popcorn and
Cricket chocolate uh chocolate covered
crickets okay and also uh cricket bird
Cricket Burger yeah now I'm going to
start slowly okay to Childhood with the
chocolate covered cricket all right if I
eat that no please I I think so that is
chocolate covering a cricket yeah
correct yeah what part of the cricket
the entire well the the legs are shaking
off but it's pretty much the entire
Cricket including the loins the loins
are included in that in that piece yeah
that's right
that's delicious I I love your
willingness to try this because it's
really just like a psychological thing
to separate this isn't a cricket hopping
around the ground right it's a cricket
that was farmed and harvested for us
I'll put anything in my mouth Jeff so I
have no limits tell me what uh that's a
cricket caramel popcorn we got crickets
in there and like you know we could if
we could just think about presenting
this as food that we already recognize
we could have extreme dishes at
highlights like that's super bugified
but what about ways that are a little
more familiar for us to try to eat so I
just try to give people the options I'm
not trying to force this on anymore no I
get it I get it and it's really like hey
if you want to try it I'd love to share
this with you if you don't then I'm also
very fine with that 100 well I eat I'd
eat chocolate covered crickets all day
um let's take that to the bank now I'm
not gonna eat this right now because
it's frankly it's too early here in Los
Angeles for me but can you tell us what
that is that just looks like a hamburger
yeah so that's a that's a cricket burger
that we form right and it's not a
hundred percent Cricket like a beef
burger because we need to fill it with
like other things to give it the mouth
feel the texture of a real Burger it's
going to be a little more specific about
these others so we use like soy and like
aromatics like onions and garlic and we
also use like different sort of uh like
yeast like the the yeast and it really
just kind of like gives it like a nice
mouth feel and flavor
hmm I'm just gonna I'm gonna smell it
and then I'm just gonna nibble on it
okay you know what if it if if eating
together kind of helps you know what I'm
just you know what I trust you so much
forget the morning time the first bug
Chef I've ever met I'm just gonna go
ahead and do it thank you yeah bug out
petite
that's not bad at all it's actually
pretty good um Can it roughly I'm not
gonna hold you to it but how many
crickets per Burger would you say
well in this burger we have a it's
mostly the powder that I use and each
one has probably like about one
tablespoon which is uh one to two
tablespoons of cricket powder and how
many crickets does that represent that
I'd have to get back to you on I don't
know exactly how many and I assume
they're humanely killed yeah
okay I'm not going to ask for details on
that okay
um Chef you if anybody can sell this
country on bugs it's you and we're
grateful that you took the time to show
us our future and I I'll say for the for
the cricket corn it's excellent you know
thank you so much for your interest in
in sharing the work that we do I think
whether people like it or dislike it
it's important just to give people the
option and so that's really what I'm
really grateful for the opportunity to
share this work with you thank you very
much well thank you I appreciate it Chef
Yoon subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight